you might think that $500 is pretty
steep for a console these days but it
could be much worse here are the 10 most
expensive home consoles of all time at
launch adjusted for inflation I'll
explain my workings at the end of the
video if you want to see how it was all
calculated picture the scene it's 1995
and the big buzz around E3 is about the
Sega satin and Sony PlayStation finally
coming to America you are approaching
Saturn say was winning in Japan and
hoped to bring that momentum to the
United States the Saturn was due to
launch in the fall but Sega took to the
stage at E3 to say that not only would
the console be available at
$399 it would also be available right
now in the United States that is Sony's
head of development Steve race then took
to the stage simply said
[Applause]
[Music]
299 the Sony PlayStation was $100
cheaper than its direct competitor but
when you adjust that to today's money
it's still comes in at around
$59 that story is one of the true mic
drop moments in gaming and also rained
on sega's Parade but more on that
later in at nine the Xbox 360 honestly I
didn't expect to see it in this list
because of how affordable that console
would eventually become with various
bundles and Hardware revisions but when
it launched in 2005 the full Xbox 360
package cost $399 with the cheaper core
package costing just 299 the Xbox 360
package was pretty comprehensive though
it included the console a detachable 20
GB hard drive wireless controller
headset cables a face plate an Xbox live
silver membership as well as the fangled
Xbox 360 media remote control adjusted
for 2020 that rounds out to about
$531 which is a little hard to swallow
especially when you consider how many
red ring of death issues eventually
popped up with that console
hot off the heels of the success of the
Xbox 360's enormous sales figures Xbox
had a rough go with the launch of its
successor the Xbox one due to a string
of bad PR about its rumored always
online functionality DRM it's
over-the-top messaging about TV
integration lack of emphasis on gaming
and then its price point an eyew
watering
$99 which is about 556 in 2020 money
unlike the 360 which offered a cheaper
launch package alternative xbone only
had one which contained a 500 GB console
One controller and everyone's favorite
peripheral the connect funnny enough
they dropped the connect package after 8
months I'm not going to dwell on the
satin here too much as I already spilled
the beans on its launch price
$399 today that would be roughly 680
even though Sega beat PlayStation to the
US market by a good few months
unfortunately it didn't have the games
to capitalize on the head start when the
PlayStation launched in September 1995
it sold more units in 2 days than the
Saturn had in its 5 months on the
market we'll talk a little bit more
about the Atari 2600 in a minute but the
console successor the more powerful 5200
makes a little appearance on this list
first releasing in 1982 at $269 that's
724 in today's money the 5200 didn't
really set the world on fire yes it had
better graphics than the 2600 but it was
unable to play the vast majority of 2600
games until they released an adapter the
following year another reminder why
backwards compatibility is super
important Riding High after the
PlayStation 2's enormous success and
with its direct competitor the Xbox 360
already out all eyes were on Sony to see
what it could pull out of the bag for
the PlayStation 3 unfortunately the
attention the PS3 got was for all the
wrong reasons the console cost
$599 for this 60 GB model that's 772 in
today's money the reason Sony was way
too ambitious the technology inside the
PS3 including its Infamous cell
microprocessor CPU made it expensive to
manufacture pushing the price up however
Sony was remarkably Forward Thinking in
being the first Home console to adopt
the blue blay player and thanks to some
price cuts and well-received first party
titles it managed to pull it all
back back in the early '70s if you had a
Home console you'd only be able to play
one game on it meaning that developing
game consoles was frankly not really
worth it if you wanted to keep up with
the ever expanding video game industry
it wasn't until developers began to
experiment with microprocessors in their
consoles that you could play multiple
games at home on one machine the Atari
20 600 launched in 1977 at $199 $853 in
today's money and it had a slow start
even requiring some cash injections to
keep Atari afloat it's the 2600 from
Atari eventually though the console
began to gather Steam and when Atari
licensed Space Invaders and released it
in 1980 console sales quickly began to
rise but still 800 bucks is a lot of
money all right now we're getting into
the big money Mattel yes the Barbie and
Hot Wheels toy manufacturer had a line
of handheld electronic games in the70s
and after seeing Atari release the 2600
in 1977 began work on its own Home
console the Intel Vision launching for
$299 in 1979 that's 1,070 bucks in
today's money the Intel vision's initial
release was pretty slow as it only
launched in select markets with four
games with one of them being literally a
game about mats the television
eventually found its footing by
marketing how advanced it was compared
to Atari with higher resolution graphics
and Better
Sound Time magazine's 1993 product of
the year is in at number two the 3dio it
launched at
$699 that is around
$1,257 in today's money yes you heard me
right already it was super expensive and
unfortunately for the 3dio console
because the 3dio company were making TW
to it all the way down to the wire it
launched with only one game one and that
game was called Crash and Burn you can't
make it
up the Neo Geo multivideo system an
arcade machine with a bunch of different
games inside it compared to just one
launched back in 1990 it was a super
powerful system and due to the
versatility of being able to swap ROM
cartridges and artwork it became very
successful in arcades seeing an
opportunity manufacturer SNK developed
the Neo Geo Advanced Entertainment
System what a mouthful and rented them
out to places like bars restaurants and
game rental stores demand to bring the
arcade experience to the home row and
the Neo Geo was released as a Home
console in 1991 for
$649 that's
$1,290 in 2020 money the console was
super powerful for its time but the
price of it and its games which would
retail for over $100 each meant that
enough it never really caught on of
course now the Neo Geo and many of its
games are collector's items among arcade
enthusiasts so there we are the top 10
most expensive home consoles adjusted
for inflation I used US inflation
calculator.com and rounded up the
numbers for ease thanks for watching and
for more on the PS5 and Xbox series X
and S make sure to keep your eyes peeled
to
[Music]
GameSpot